märz gedacht und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen koffer video ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut ich muss sagen ich
hatte das lange im kopf das unbedingt
noch mal zu machen und ja so ein paar
optionen habe ich verpasst aber ich habe
mir eine eingetragen den nicht so ganz
also es war eher ein zufall ich hatte
irgendwie im hinterkopf in den nächsten
tag ist eine auktion dann habe ich mal
reingeschaut und dann war die genau
gerade ablaufen also war auch echt ein
bisschen glück dabei und dann dachte ich
mir kommen musst du deine chance nutzen
mal wieder ordentlich was ersteigern
aber mit taktik diesmal wenn ihr die
letzten beiden koffer an bord ging es
noch nicht gesehen habt checkt die auf
jeden fall mal ab wir haben dort
insgesamt über 1000 euro bezahlt was an
sich für den inhalt der koffer viel zu
viel geld war also wirklich viel zu viel
und ja da habe ich mir überlegt was kann
man anders machen mir ist aufgefallen so
handgepäcks koffer habe ich trotzdem für
relativ wenig geld bekommen und dann war
sie meinen plan erkauft doch nicht so 15
und 20 kilogramm kupfer sondern einfach
acht kilogramm koffer weil da ist auch
viel wert drin meine taktik erkläre ich
euch kurz zum sitzen taktik besprechen
mir ist aufgefallen ich habe beim
letzten mal wirklich für zwei koffer
sowie 150 300 euro bezahlt nur weil das
irgendwie 20 kilogramm kupfer waren so
fette koffer keine handgepäcks koffer
bei uns so wenn wir wirklich immer zwei
wochen weg gefahren mit der familie dann
hatte jeder so einen fetten koffer jetzt
ich reiße eigentlich nur mit handgepäck
egal wie lange ich weg wäre jetzt packt
mich immer so oder so lange anzustehen
ich hasse das aber wenn man mal logisch
nach denkt in so fette koffer klar die
nimmt man mit wenn man viele klamotten
braucht und natürlich sind klamotten
auch was wert aber handgepäcks kopf hat
sind ja nicht unbedingt weniger wert
weil im handgepäck opfern du brauchst
immer deine teuren sachen braucht seine
kopfhörer du brauchst eine digitalkamera
du brauchst seine was weiß ich deswegen
ist mein plan günstiger handgepäcks kopf
hat zu ersteigern weil ich vom wert her
nicht unbedingt schlechter sind ich
hoffe das könnte man jetzt verstehen und
damit gehen wir ins studio zu mir nach
hause
leute was geht ich sitze gerade spontan
hier an koffern die gebote sind viel
höher als beim letzten mal ne hoffe ich
mal dass ich ein paar coole koffer
bekomme ich bin gerade jetzt bieten wir
hier auf diesen trolley da sollen nur
auf und jagten drin sein aber ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass sie
siebeneinhalb kilo wiegen in einem
kleinen deswegen hab ich einfach mal mit
geboten und hier auf diesen rucksack
auch mit 816 rückseite wo lebe ich
eigentlich da sind bestimmt drei
portionen sind und eine trinkflasche
guckt euch das mal ein koffer circa 10 5
420 euro alter werd dich junge wie kann
man da den 24 oder aufbieten bist du
dumm hier habe ich auch mal mit geboten
kinder gesagt da bin ich auch noch
höchst bieten damit 27 ein bisschen mehr
geboten das ist jetzt gleich auch vorbei
ok jetzt bin ich etwas beruhigt werden
noch einige trolleys die ihnen diese
kategorie ja gut das steht ja auch
kopper habe wieder lust den hier möchte
ich gern haben gehen wir mal mit 80 euro
mit das müssen wir daraus geben ich will
nicht mehr als 100 euro bezahlen kommen
90 hey leute ohne witz wenn ich auf
diesen kinder rucksack überboten werden
mit 27 euro dann komme ich nicht klar
ein kind hat ja nicht viel wertsachen
dabei oder obwohl man weiß ja nie die
kinder heutzutage die haben auch stellen
war schon in der zweiten klasse ein
iphone oder kindergarten ist das erne
komm gib mir einfach diese
trottel man wie so was willst du damit
36 euro für ein kinderbuch sein ich muss
los mal vor ich bezahlt 50 euro für
kinder rucksack okay dann haben wir
schon mal bekommen weiter geht dann
gehen wir jetzt hier noch auf den stark
gebraucht also der koffer ist stark
gebraucht der inhalt hoffentlich nicht
mehr ist denn hier ja ja ja okay das
sieht wirklich gebraucht wird schon
schräglage ok komme und gib mir den mut
auch noch der schiefste koffer der welt
ich glaube ohne wird es beim letzten mal
habe ich über 1000 euro und die bezahlte
bietet einer mit scheiß gibt mir den
koffer gibt mir den koffer bleibt bleibt
bleibt
ok damit bin ich zufrieden 90 euro für
den koffer warum auch nicht hoffen wir
mal dass das sich lohnt ich komme ja mal
so ein ahlmann rucksack da sind bestimmt
auch ganz viele tupperdosen drin ohne
scheiß diesen rucksack haben doch 95
prozent aller lehrer oder da sind
bisschen ganz viele schulbücher drin den
möchte ich gar nicht haben er hier sieht
eigentlich noch ganz gut aus leute ich
würde einfach mal sagen ich biete jetzt
so ein bisschen mit und wir sehen uns
dann wieder wenn die koffer da sind dann
zeige ich euch was ich alles geboten
habe und das dauert jetzt ja ich doch
ein bisschen deswegen das lohnt sich
glaube ich nicht dass alles mit
aufzunehmen bis später so herzlich
willkommen zurück gaben noch zwei
weitere koffer ersteigert der eine 74
kilo der andere 7,3 der andere 7,1 unten
kinder rucksack bezahlt habe ich jetzt
insgesamt dafür 474 euro 33 also halb so
viel wie beim letzten mal und ich hoffe
das lohnt sich metzger alter bock leute
schotter was angekommen ist ein
das ist schon mal geil ich muss sagen
ein koffer fehlt auch leider noch der
kommt erst der motor die ich sage ich
muss einfach mal reinschauen
ich habe schon so viele koffer
und da müsste eigentlich
weiß ich noch nicht ganz fertig aber auf
jeden fall einiges gekauft hat gesehen
wir machen das heute einfach mal hier
auf dem boden also starten zumindest mal
sowie anwalts koffer
3273 schau mal rein ich sage immer ich
mag es beim nächsten mal besser kommen
wieder keine handschuhe also wir greifen
jetzt in dem koffer rein weiß nicht ob
der vor oder nach urlaub beziehungsweise
reise war und nein das sieht naja
spricht eigentlich alles ganz frisch für
die die sich mit koffer option noch
nicht so auskennen bargeld teure
wertgegenstände wie smartphones iphones
was auch immer drogen oder sonstiges
werden vorher raus genommen also die
koffer werden leider alle kontrolliert
das finde ich scheiße und ich will
eigentlich meinen koffer haben ja nicht
kontrolliert ist jemand von euch arbeit
doch bestimmt beim zoll da kann man doch
mal was machen für mich über instagram
30 alex wir haben eine wunderschöne
weste von olé olé olé olé das ist auf
jeden fall und damen koffer wäre das
jetzt täglich wenn ich das an sich wird
das gern einmal gucken wir das an mir
aussieht und kleidchen bis jetzt ein
bisschen langweilig okay let's go hey
das war ja auf jeden fall wenn ich alles
ausgepackt habe ich mir das heftigste
outfit raus und sie das einmal selber an
und euch zu vermitteln diese frau und
ist zwar ein bisschen eklig aber ist mir
egal ich hier noch unfassbar geile
schuhe von es führt wird auch mal
behaupten das sind alles machen jetzt
keinen wert haben also vielleicht tue
ich mich da auch aber wer weiß das sieht
auf jeden fall schon ein bisschen
interessanter aus die sachen die wir
gerade ausgepackt haben und hier wird es
jetzt hoffentlich cool der kleidungsstil
von dieser frau meiner meinung nach
absolut vollkatastrophe
jedem das seine wir haben ja was aus dem
duty-free-shop das ist irgendwie so
einen backmischungen oder so was heißt
auch nicht genau was das sein soll
kommen diesmal aus es ist irgendwie so
eine afrikanische beauty maske das ist
ja richtig glücklich das möchte ich
jetzt nicht drauf machen habe ich angst
dass ich mal wieder ausschlag oder so
also ich mache ja wirklich eigentlich
alles für ein video aber das muss jetzt
gerade nicht sein pafl da ist wirklich
leider nicht mehr viel drin wir schauen
mal was das kostet ich bin euch den
preis hier ein das ist nämlich nina
ricci es sollte für frauen ja brauche
ich das stark nicht zu 100 prozent mein
fall wenn ich eine abschleppen würde die
dieses verfilmt regt auch egal war das
geht gar nicht man könnte auch denken
das gehört einem baby haben eine bürste
ohne mütze junge zu welt geschickt das
geschick dass das ist eine beschickt das
müze von besiktas istanbul also ich muss
wirklich sagen dieser koffer löste in
mir verwirrung aus ich würde zu gerne
ein foto sehen von der besitzerin wie
sie aussieht das wird nicht so
interessieren ich glaube es ist ein
weiblicher chinesischer geschickt dass
istanbul fan das wird so ein komischer
eigentlich darf man so was ja gar nicht
mitführen der viel zu viel man darf ja
eigentlich nur bis 150 millilitern im
handgepäck und das ist auch nicht in
plastikfolie ich weiß nicht vielleicht
nichts daran weil deshalb nein ich kann
es nicht sein haben wir die raid dies
auf jeden fall fresh kann man eigentlich
sagen für diese brille bekomme ich
bestimmt auch 50 60 euro 100 euro habe
ich kriege zahl für den koffer und daher
ist das würde ich mal sagen in ordnung
also hätte ich dafür 200 euro bezahlt
wäre es definitiv ein flop aber so geht
es noch halbwegs dann würde ich sagen
ich hier mal kurz eine umkleidekabine
wir sehen
derzeit sind jetzt auch nicht so groß
also ich wette diesmal genauso warum
genau muss ich noch die schuhe anziehen
schwul hier sind wahrscheinlich größte
24 und als kleines extra natürlich noch
die sein dass sich das geschieht das
geschieht das
die aktion ist
okay leute wir machen den nächsten auge
ich bin gespannt erste wahl so ja ok ich
muss mal ehrlich sagen was ich ein
bisschen komisch findet wir hatten zum
beispiel in den letzten koffern auch
genauso eine ray ban das ist es
irgendwie so ein bisschen ich denke
manchmal dass ist so auch bisschen
gefaked von dem auch das mit dem 400
milliliter duschgel macht meines
erachtens gar kein sind deswegen leute
würde ich auch irgendwie ein kopfball
unkontrolliert das wird viel geiler der
kinder rucksack hat mich ja auch nur 40
euro kostet wo leben wir eigentlich und
dann haben wir hier noch ein koffer drin
war dann lass uns mal erst mal den mann
hier habe ich nämlich noch so ein
schwarzes köpfchen schuhe das ist männer
koffer das gefällt mir jetzt bin ich
wirklich gespannt darum sind diese
schuhe nicht weiß wer trägt heutzutage
noch rote schuhe ich filme euch das mal
kurz ab hier haben wir die roten schuhe
kopfhörer wieder die haben wir einen
kulturbeutel jetzt bin ich wirklich mal
gespannt größte 43 wer gut dann kann ich
dir wenigstens mal anprobieren made in
china alter so dicker von primark sind
die das heißt die kosten neu schon nicht
mehr als 20 euro und hier jetzt
wahrscheinlich nicht mal 5 sowie die
aussehen und ich muss auch sagen da ich
jetzt direkt schon schuhe von primark
darin gefunden habe glaube ich nicht
dass der sonst teure klamotten getragen
hat da sind haare hätte ich fürchte
wirklich handschuhen und seht ihr das da
sind haare dran an der badehose was
machen solche haare
größe ist mir zu klein auch das merke
ich jetzt schon dann haben wir hier die
nächste hose vom optischen her also das
sind sowohl sind die habe ich so 2016
habe ich die getragen hat ist timberlake
29 mehr auch viel zu klein
dies verlangen die hose aber hier oben
halten so wie dumm kann man denn sein
also ist besser jetzt könnt ihr auch
direkt anschauen die haben wir die
nächste hose auch wieder check-in jones
also hier haben wir den richtigen
check-in jones fällt hier
das sind sowohl sie sind ja immer noch
im trend heute sind überall so flecken
auf muster so kopfhörer es kann doch
nicht sein in den letzten kopf haben
waren auch auf kopfhörer da ist nicht
mal eine marke drauf er uns heute wenn
die irgendwohin viel wenn ich irgendwo
hinfliegen im flugzeug da sind ganz ganz
viele menschen die haben kopfhörer auf
aber ich habe noch nie jemanden gesehen
der kopfhörer auf hat von daten von so
so wie soll ich hier versteht ihr was
ich meine also ich finde das alles ein
bisschen suspekt ina oberteil ja wo
junge voll dreckig dann haben wir hier
so eine decke und das war es dann auch
schon haben wir dann auch das nächste
paar unterhosen ich weiß nicht ob die
benutzte das finde ich jetzt auch nicht
herausfindet da made in france ich weiß
nicht also dieser koffer der enttäuscht
mich sehr so ist das was willst du
machen ich würde sagen das war jetzt
schon mal zwei koffer ich habe halt noch
viel mehr bestellt leute ich würd sagen
wir belasten das jetzt erstmal hierbei
hinter mir könnt ihr nochmal das ganze
chaos begutachten ich bin gespannt was
in den nächsten coup an drin ist und
auch in dem rucksack da kann man mal
kurz rein wahrscheinlicher
butterbrotdosen und sohn zigaretten habe
ich mir doch gedacht und mit body er hat
es ordentlich krachen lassen im
kindergarten leute lasst mir super gerne
auch nach oben da denkt dran wenn die
irgendwo wisst wo gibt's koffer
ungeprüft meldet euch bei alex instagram
alex wie abonniert super gern den kanal
und wir sehen uns in ein zwei drei tagen
da gibt es das nächste video
vielen dank fürs zuschauen